warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised
hey everyone welcome to LED live today
we are going to address the question of
what the science have to say about
homosexuality find out on this episode
of LED live we've done a couple of
programs on this and we've had some
questions so we decided on this episode
we would bring a real scientist a
biologist a PhD in biology dr. Aaron
Corbett is here with us today to address
this issue dr. Korba thank you for being
here okay I suppose it's good to be here
I have to admit being a little bit
nervous about this I was noticing you
guys have a lot of subscribers I think I
was looking was like 50,000 or something
like that
which is I was doing this you know back
of the napkin calculations think of all
the students assuming that no no student
repeated a class in the seven years I've
been teaching at southern animist
University it came to I don't know 2500
so you're like an order of magnitude in
terms of higher than anybody I've ever
done I know that and I guess I'm I'm oh
I even when I teach this in a class that
I teach to southern and talk about these
issues it's always a little bit nervous
isn't you know because this is such a
hot topic
it raises people's emotions quite a bit
I guess they want to be careful about
not coming across in a way that is
unhelpful or reflects poorly on Christ
or you know those type of things and
that's very easy to do when you talk
about that's right issue well it's the
number one reason why we wanted to do
shows like this is because we need to
understand and sometimes you know I'm
not a homosexual so it's like for me to
try to wrap my head around how to be
sensitive to this to to someone that is
struggling in that field but then also
still aiming them at Christ I mean
that's that's yeah thanks I've got to
say the same issue I struggle with I
mean I don't know this is and this might
still be a work in progress I mean how
do you relate science and this issue and
what your Bible says and all that kind
of stuff but yeah I'm not
I don't have same-sex attractions either
okay so you know trying to get inside
and really listen and understand what
the evidence is and what it isn't is it
is a challenge and that's that's one of
the things I found it's looking at this
issue it really any issue I've ever
looked at whether it's what I did to mid
dissertation on whether it's you know
and everything reality is complicated
there's always new ones there's always
complexity that goes in it and so you've
got to be careful about really listening
I think one of the texts that I like is
from private things private 18 text
about that to answer a matter before
hearing is shame and folly that's right
and so really taking the time to listen
and understand before you try and have
an opinion on it I released Lisa a solid
opinion it's really good biblical
counsel yeah follow well if you read any
of the comments on some of the videos
that we've created on this there is a
plethora of people that have a lot to
say on this topic so I'm excited to dive
into this and here which is alright I
guess I need to do plug my my own media
that I'm trying to get awesome it there
so I start starting a podcast and I
don't know we're kind of slow burning
right now because I have to try and be a
full time professor and so this is a
podcast it's called nature and
revelation it's about science and faith
issues we might want to branch out I
don't know I have one YouTube video up
there I think of an awesome
but yeah so if you want to check that
out would be nature and revelation dot
o-r-g awesome so kind of blending
biology and Christianity yeah that's
what we talked about so I mean the first
podcast we've done that are up there I
think we all do we have seven of them so
far that um they're they're really
focusing on you know it's it's evolution
and origins issues how to relate to that
what I loved is how science I mean real
true science when you really look at it
it really does point to a finger
somebody's created this thing and I
think it kind of pulls Janet through
well certainly there's plenty in there
that screams design yeah I think you
certainly need scripture to get a full
picture
hhor-- by itself can ya testify too
designed I just read a book recently
on the design I think it was called the
new Origin of Species are you familiar
with that I am NOT is written by a
Harvard biologist okay and I think his
last name was Jenson and it brought up a
lot of really interesting things that I
had never thought about before and so
anyway if you're interested in creation
design models you might check that book
out we'll see if we can put it in the
link below all right well I guess I do
want to start just when we talk about
this issue just making sure that we're
in kind of the right place because I
have had interactions with people I mean
I'm a scientist I go to assign to the
conventions I have just met people let's
say on Facebook right and the the
attitude that comes out especially when
you talk of a secular world secular
academic world in terms to Christianity
is one of you know there's a little bit
of disgust there right and the reason
for that kind of has to do with the idea
of you know you Christians you think
you're just so better than everybody
else
you're holier than thou and the term
that's often used is a moralizing look
there we go
so this is a quote that came from this
is a book I'm just starting to read this
is the very first chapter
it's basically science and ethics it's
basically a book all about how you how
science informs ethics and morals this
first chapter is by was it Paul Koontz I
think that's how you pronounce his name
it was actually very well known I think
he was very well known as secular
humanists and atheists so the first
chapter is sort of dripping with sort of
this anti religious sentiment mmm-hmm
but this I thought was interesting so he
talks about so the danger of moralizing
so you got some degree of skepticism is
necessary as a necessary antidote to all
forms of ethical certainty we are
continually surrounded by self-righteous
moralist who claim that they have the
absolute moral virtue or piety or nor
the secret path to salvation and wish to
impose their convictions on others and
he goes on they are puffed up with an
inflated sense of their own rectitude as
they rail against unbeknown immemorial
sinners who lack their moral faith these
ethical systems so he's talking about
you know certain religious systems
become especially dangerous when they
are appeal
to in order to legislate morality and
then he goes on that last good hell hath
no fury like the self-righteous moralist
scorned and so yeah this is you every
time we talk about this issue I'm sure
you know if you if you have people
looking at your channel or you know that
are let's say atheist or secular
humanists they're gonna be like I'm sure
this is the first thing that comes into
their mind and what I found interesting
when I read this particular quote is
that I don't think he's alone in having
this view hmm I think Jesus is a person
who actually had the same view about
people who stand up above others in
terms of placing themselves on a higher
you know higher moral plane than
everybody else interesting and the place
that that comes out I think this is a
Luke 18 so the parable of the Pharisee
in the tax collector sure and if you
look there verse 9 a very start this is
who the parable is directed to do you
know the the author here is telling you
who the parable is directed Tunes is to
some who were confident in their own
righteousness and look down on everyone
else Jesus told this parable and to some
I mean that's kind of like there cease
because it's a Pharisee stood by himself
right and he's like I look at me I'm
great and wonderful and I tithe and I'm
not like that tax collector over there
and so Jesus to say oh yeah you
Pharisees you who think you are one the
moral high ground you are the ones are
in danger not the repentance center down
below so this is and yeah often times
when even Christians talk about this
issue on media anywhere they go this is
this is what it looks like to most
people out there so we got to be careful
very careful when you talk about this
issue let's talk about kind of what this
presentation is guys this is talking
it's kind of based on this so this is
Lady gaga this is the actually even
articles I read from homosexuals who
have you know talked about this issue
what causes it this is like a pivotal
thing in society about what how you
reason the moral reasoning behind
whether homosexuality is right or wrong
it's like she's popularized this
particular show at the end this way I
mean the lyrics are kind of interesting
I pulled some out here yeah so I'm
beautiful in my way cause God makes no
mistake
right there's some theology here right
I'm on the right track baby I was born
this way and of course this is she's
very clear in the lyrics that she's
talking about you know non-heterosexual
types of sexuality hmm that's okay right
I'm on the right track
even if I'm gay straight bi lesbian
whatever it is and so this is dominate
and usually the the dynamic I see in in
media is one of you you kind of take
this well that either if you're born
that way then that's a straight line to
saying that it's okay to be that way
right and acting to behave in whatever
ways go along with right because it's
not your fault I didn't choose how you
would be born yeah and so yeah it tries
to go in with I mean oftentimes this is
kind of the the top way because it tries
to tie in with like the civil rights
movement because of course I'm born with
your skin color you can't change it you
know that kind of a thing and so if
you're born that way this is right
almost justifies and I'm sure I'm gonna
get into this how much does culture
actually influence the biology yeah well
we'll look at some of that I mean
theories about how how it comes about
and so actually the other the other side
is even you know Christian groups will
pick up on this and they still use this
same premise they the the hinge is the
premise are you born that way or not
right one interesting side note we did a
video on her sheep for claims to be a
Christian she talks about she prays
before yeah okay and then actually comes
out in this she talks about you know
capital h-i-m and but then another song
she says her and says like how much he's
in love with judas and you know it's
like well I mean it was it was tough to
watch this video because there's
hyper-sexualized yeah
even this I was looking at this thing
going what is this about it right like
full the full image it's like hurry and
proposed onto a motorcycle great yeah
and it's like I was thinking what what
is that supposed to symbolize like what
do you do with a motorcycle
I guess you ride a motorcycle is for she
designed to be and that doesn't seem
like a very uplifting message for women
right right
anyway so yeah even Christians I think
get into this and so what you have is
Christian literature that will try and
say no you're not born that way and
somehow if you're born that way then
it's not a choice and that
somehow leads you down a path of saying
this is okay and if it's you know if if
if you aren't born that way that somehow
it's on you and it's your choice and
whatever and that and so yeah so what I
want to do is actually look at that but
yeah I just start by looking at some
just statistics here this is some
statistics there's a range depending on
which study you look at of how what
percent of the population is identifies
as something other than heterosexual so
you buy up three and a half percent of
the US population identify as gay
lesbian or bisexual and that number
varies so some they'll say four percent
and it depends how you measure it to
this still current today this is this
current this is fairly current yes
because it seems like it's becoming more
and more prevalent I mean I have people
in my immediate circle that I know that
are gay and I mean I'm sure you guys
have people that you know I mean it's
just it's like like yeah numbers in that
just seem yeah I wonder a little bit but
everything I read would suggest in
especially the things I was looking at
particularly for this presentation
there's these two big review papers one
is by a fairly conservative group that's
in the journal called the new Atlantic
and I think they're fairly conservative
but the other one was by a guy named Jay
Michael Bailey who's at Northwestern
University in Chicago who is very much
sort of you know yeah and so but the
case that seems to be made is this this
this number hasn't really varied through
time right interest and its might just
become more prominent more accepted and
that's why you see it more right but
again it depends how you measured if you
guys give somebody a survey and there's
what it's called the Kinsey scale and
you ask them you know on one side are
you completely straight or cut you know
homosexual on one side and there's
there's a few options in between you
know mostly bisexual you know you get
about three and a half four percent the
the interesting one I looked at was
there was one that was looked at Google
searches and ask the question what
percent of the population actually
searches for homosexual pornography
mm-hmm and based on that they were
estimating maybe a step closer to eight
percent so somewhere in that ballpark
can be fully accurate I mean straight
men might look at lesbian yeah that's
true that's true that's true
so you know this is you know four
percent isn't you know
it's not a lot it's not a lot but it's a
lot it's a number of when you consider
you're talking what is it over 300 plus
million people invest and if you're at a
number of about nine nine million people
yeah they've been able to actually sway
legislation to completely change our
ways of thinking and rules and laws in
their countries it's fascinating to me
well I just go back to the quote from
earlier where he talked about you know
legislating morality from was it Koontz
yeah yeah and I'm like well that's a
double-edged sword because there's all
kinds of people that are trying to
legislate their own version of morality
right yeah so only yeah I mean I
certainly would agree with separation
George is safe but I guess that does
work both ways one hand we don't want to
legislate morality on either side of any
moral issue right really I agree kind of
hand you know so here's our distribution
if you do that Kinsey score you can see
here completely heterosexual mostly
heterosexual bisexual mostly
heterosexual or completely
homosexual you can see the vast majority
of people are completely hetero things
yeah you can see here they've walked you
cut it off so we have you know of men
right this is 90 plus 93 94 percent
we're gonna say I am completely
heterosexual women's you know that's
women's a little bit less there yes is
one of the interesting things that came
out looking at some of this is that
women are kind of built slightly
different in terms of their sexuality
the men are mmm-hmm you'll find more
there's a little bit more what's
described in the literature of sexual
fluidity and females that means maybe
they're more like wanting emotional
connect yeah there's maybe emotional
component there but you'll notice here
if it's completely heterosexual men are
the majority of men there's a fewer
females if you like mostly men females
are higher than males with bisexuals you
if this is self identifying more females
than males are going to identify as
bisexual interesting uh so and yeah if
you look at that completely homosexual
it's mostly males it's mostly males
right
so part of that really does have to do
with this phenomena in the research too
that's because most research is actually
done in males because they understand
our male sexual orientation they well
they're good they will do stuff that you
know we might consider unethical type
research is basically let's put some
electrodes on your genitals and show you
pornography and ngoi oh all right
and who would sign up yeah so a what you
find is you know if it arouses a man
that goes right along with the sexual
orientation it doesn't always with women
Wow interesting
no their head yeah and sometimes they
they women will see me especially if
it's close you know personal intimate
relationship with another female they
might actually feel some sexual
attraction in that situation where a man
might probably would not there's more
relational base than face yes it's more
relational base so yeah it's interesting
so because men are simpler we sort of
more research is geared there's that's
kind of how science works if it's a
simple thing we know more okay yeah if
it's complicated we know that's just one
figured out so let's see here let's this
is another thing to keep in mind and
this is gonna become important as we
interpret some of the other results of
some of the data that we're gonna look
at and that is this idea of gender
nonconformity
and what you find is that the majority
of people who you know identify as
homosexual will have had some sort of
gender non-conforming behavior as
children hmm you can see there it's like
eighty-nine percent of men who are
homosexual so this is basically desiring
to you know guys playing with girl stuff
in a very not just I occasionally put on
a dress or something so this is like a
recognize this is really something you
recognize early okay and this is you
know the same for lets you know
homosexual women you start it starts out
so there's a very you know and that's
going to come play a role here now this
isn't quite the same as transgender
gender dysphoria isn't right the same
thing so they think these people are
still identify
as males but they really like to play
with dolls stuff like this alright
and this seems to continue into
adulthood so you know we often people
joke sometimes about gaydar mm-hmm like
I can tell just by looking at someone
what they are and actually that
apparently this has some basis in
science so when they've done stuff you
know movement pattern speech physical
presentations facial appearance
cognitive personality trades yeah they
seem to match they're not quite with
what's typical I remember gender growing
up and recognizing from an early age
okay this this person is is acting or
gets along with the females more than
them boys and sure enough you know you
just wait long enough and in their adult
life you see the little posts of how
they've come out of the closet or
whatever and so yeah I mean III I've
written
witnessed this in my own life so yeah
this this this doesn't really fit with
like any particular theory about why but
it does come into play when we're going
to interpret some of the data that comes
up so that's why I put it up here in the
beginning but let's see here let's look
causes of homosexuality this is what's
in the literature we've got four of them
here four major ones one is hormones one
is genes non social environment and then
social environment so non social
environment would be just stuff you're
exposed to that doesn't have to do with
interactions with other people right
social environment has to do with
interactions with their people so if
someone molested but yeah so so that
kind of a thing parent-child
relationships you know interpersonal
relation to anybody whether it's abuse
or whatever it is right so and the other
thing to keep in mind here is that these
aren't necessarily mutually exclusive
causes sure right because we know genes
are gonna influence hormone production
how you you know environmental input
might expect how you express a gene or
express the hormone
so it could be none of these it could be
all of these right these aren't
necessarily mutually exclusive so we're
gonna go through these kind of one at a
time and what kind of start with
hormones here and the first thing to
talk about is there's actually an
interesting way apparently to kind of
figure out how much testosterone you're
exposed to as a as a kind of young
developing fetus in your mother's womb
and has to do with finger length ratios
hmm
so it's the second digit of forth digits
and in anatomy physiology you count the
digits this is the two thumbs digit 1 so
it's 1 2 3 4 5 so it's the index finger
and your ring finger the ratio of the
lengths so if there's a if those are
equal
all right I've been equally so basically
it's women have larger ratios than men
so they have a longer index finger tend
you know proportionally to the ring
finger interesting all right ok so yeah
everyone at this point I'm sure is
looking at themselves you know what am i
all right
so I guess my ring 4 is a little longer
so yeah man should have a little bit
longer so that's you know a little bit
more testosterone so what we find though
is homosexual women tend have a more
masculine ratio interesting okay so as I
suggest at a woman's hand you can tell
if she's more masculine is that bad yet
mmm I don't know if it's when you when
you do statistics is always on average
and so on average do you find this but
sometimes you know just because the
averages are slightly different in
deserts that it doesn't mean it's easy
to tell just by looking
oh yeah you have a ratio that says so I
don't know if how you know
you know scripted or you know die how
well it diagnoses right that right but
at least on average moderate correlation
you know so you see a correlation
coefficient there that goes between zero
and one well zero yeah anyway so it's
kind of moderate there but the unless
it's there notice there that the ratio
doesn't find a difference between guys
so homosexual male and a heterosexual
males seem to have roughly the same
interesting so alright that's
interesting we can move on here to
another this is hmm
certain developmental issues that come
up so you know what happens the first
one here we've got this is called
congenital adrenal hyperplasia which is
in women especially in women guys can
have this too but it's more interesting
to think about in women so these are
women that have a disorder to show your
adrenal glands sit right on top of your
kidneys and they actually are involved
in producing some androgens now in males
testes take over and that's really the
only game in town but if you're female
the some of the androgens they do have
some of these much less but they're
produced by the adrenal glands and so
hyperplasia has to do with lots of cells
overproduction overproduction of these
androgens and so from a very early you
know even then developing in the womb
they are you know flushed with male
hormones and so you know this is often
cotton there's things that you can do
about it but what they track these
people usually what happens this will
actually have outward physical effects
alright so what I've got here is in
during development so the the
development of tissue that's gonna make
a vagina versus a penis it's all the
same tissue the same embryonic tissue
that makes testes also makes over it's
interesting yeah so if you just turn on
a gene says on the y chromosome we call
it sry gene it's gonna shift it you know
shift development and so what happens if
there you're loaded with these male
hormones even though you're genetically
female this in this particular situation
as you often have the kind of a halfway
in-between type of a thing so you know
the kind of the outer parts of the parts
of folds of skin outside the vagina
are kind of what fold and become scrotum
are part of the shaft of the penis the
clitoris is going to become like the
head of the penis you know those are
equivalent parts and so if you've got
what's kind of forming a vagina and now
gets a big shot of male hormones this
kind of goes I don't know what to do and
kind of ends up somewhere in the middle
so you might have what they call an
elongated clitoris so I guess this is
how common is this I don't think it's
hugely comments pretty rare I don't know
if I'd have my head you know how many
but it's it's a pretty rare thing but
they have studied this right and they
sort of say all right what what's that
what's the sexual orientation what's the
what's the outcome in terms of sexual
orientation and it turns out that women
who have this you know CAH we call it do
have higher rates of homosexuality then
and women who have not experienced this
although it the interesting is still the
majority are still heterosexual identify
services hmm so it's is a greater so you
see that sixty to seventy percent are
still heterosexual as opposed to you
know four percent which is kind of funny
average little bit less so four versus
forty is still big right still the
majority are right heterosexual and and
could you know social interaction maybe
have swayed that maybe men were kind of
like repulsed by her Anatomy or
something so she's yeah interesting yeah
could be well we'll look at that a bit
more but you know that's kind of
interesting hormones may be seemed to
have some effect here here's some other
ones that are interesting that have to
deal with this is an interesting one
complete androgen insensitivity syndrome
this is where this is these people are
genetically male I have an X and Y
chromosome the Y B gene on the Y
chromosome activates and it's you know
testes or pumping out testosterone but
the receptor that picks up the antigens
is gone is shut off so it's basically
the signal to become a male is present
but the cells that are supposed to carry
out are just not listening and so the
default it turns out is female mm-hmm so
these people have testes but they're
undescended they're up where the ovaries
would be up in the body cavity but they
have female genitalia yes and no they
don't
have a uterus they just have a vagina
though not have a baby there their
vagina sort of dead ends
interesting sometimes it's shorter or
longer some of them have to get if they
want to have sex have some
reconstructive surgery to actually make
something that you can and you can see I
mean really they look email yeah
and so but yeah they're XY they have
testes so what happens with these people
the majest majority of them identify
themselves as heterosexual females hmm
that's the way they live their lives and
actually a little bit shocking me if you
can imagine you you're you feel like
your girl you raised a girl you have the
girl least external anatomy and really
the when they figure out what's going on
is usually puberty they're like wait a
minute I should be having my period and
I'm not so then they go to the doctor
and the docs like no I hate to tell you
this you're a boy and your guys like oh
yeah head exploded yeah it's a it's kind
of rough for these people I think so but
here here's hormones this is this is the
hormones being predict but the cells
aren't picking it up but yeah what do
you call this person is this person gay
or straight right but it look like a
female but they have a Y chromosome not
common yeah this is not kind of super
rare so like it's pretty rare yeah yeah
I think I need to look it up it's
probably the you know that would do the
gene that makes the receptor to pick
stuff up is probably broken and it's not
receiving the signal here's another one
this is called 5-alpha reductase
deficiency this is an enzyme and enzymes
are basically I don't know cellular
machinery they facilitate chemical
reactions inside your body and so in
this case they're they're actually two
forms of testosterone one is kind of the
general version to testosterone and then
there's one that's like super potent
called dihydrotestosterone and 5-alpha
reductase is the enzyme that turns
testosterone into dihydrotestosterone
right so if that gene is messed up and
this person does not make the
dihydrotestosterone then what happened
is something kind of this is a weird
thing they again it they are often born
with more ambiguous genitalia kind of
like in the case of CAH but as often may
be more female the nail
and these people will basically be born
often they're assigned as a girl when
they're born
based on their genitalia but then at
puberty they get this big shot more shot
of hormones and all of a sudden you know
their testicles that were undescended
now descend and they grow a penis Oh
like could they become more virile so
what was less look at penis now is much
much more more like a penis so you can
imagine that situation where windows oh
wow around puberty I'm puberty right
it's another surprise yeah that's
another surprise so I kind of had
something that was more like a vagina
and all of a sudden everybody now I've
got a something that's much more like a
penis wow I did not know that there's
there's a lot of these things going on
like people can change like that yeah
it's it's it's crazy
sounds familiar with like hermaphrodites
we heard of that from one morphing to
the other never heard would they call
this kind of a hermaphrodite I think the
term I've seen is legit called pseudo
home Aphrodite I mean true hermaphrodite
is something like a snail or I've got
both boy parts and girl parts and I can
you know you know I'm both uh you know I
have both testes and ovaries this is
like one or you know this only there's
only one set there but you're sort of
halfway between sometimes they call that
like pseudo herm after it isn't like
yeah but yeah so what do these people
identify as many of them were raised
girls right the this is this is again
very rare the Dominican Republic is
where this was first isolated there's
like a family this family lineage of
some of this the majority of these
there's a few that they've documented
fairly well and in this case most of
them identify as heterosexual males
despite that they in spite of the fact
they were many of them raised as females
interest and they transition to first
identify as a male even though they've
kind of identified as a female this
whole time and then they sinteres chance
for it identify as a male and now they
today they eventually most of them take
on the role of a male I with my man I'm
gonna marry a woman we're gonna assume
the gender roles in that society they
really they were like a male that you
just couldn't tell they were male inside
and yeah they're yeah so yeah in other
words they like testosterone was still
present
and so you might argue that maybe that
has something to do with sexual
orientation impacts on the brain is
slower development yeah and but then you
know but finally a puberty things start
to catch up in terms of the external
anatomy mm-hmm
so kind of interesting it'd be kind of
tough to be a person like this right
right well I'm a girl and all of a
sudden whoa all right so so you can see
here basically the point here is that in
these cases we see that maybe there's
some evidence that hormones play a role
in sexual orientation mm-hmm
we see like an androgen insensitivity
apparently pick up the hormones is just
not there and so they sort of even
though they have a Y chromosome they
didn't get the hormones so I sort of end
up with a female sexual orientation
right here I did get some male hormone
by just my you know external Anatomy
didn't you know develop normally but I
still end up generally with a
heterosexual male orientation so that's
kind of interesting now that the
downside here when you look at hormones
is gonna be that usually if there's a
hormone imbalance somewhere you expect
that you know that you might expect yes
to affect the brain affect sexual
orientation but you would also expect it
to affect the genitalia as we see right
but most you know lesbians or gay people
don't have any problems with their
alright and so that's where this gets a
little bit trickier on one hand we have
a little bit of evidence to say well
maybe hormones are right but on the
other hand variety of people this
doesn't seem to apply because yeah most
people don't have issues and in the
development of their they kind of take
the biology where the you do see some of
these changes and they run with it and
apply it to sort of the big group yeah
so yeah there's a so so let's look at
the second oh yeah I missed this this is
this is another part to it this is a big
deal when it came out especially the
study by laveyan 1991 which was he find
a host finding that male homosexual
brains looked a lot like female
heterosexual brains in a particular part
in the center of the brain called the
hypothalamus and so this goes along with
the hormone hypothesis because maybe the
hormones are affecting the development
of
illness and that's pushing sexual
orientation and one way or the other but
this has been criticized too right
because how you behave affects your
brain - thanks so if I was if I was a
musician actually the interesting study
i saw is i'm this is cab drivers in
london and these are people that have
memorized the maze of streets that are
in london and they were actually
measuring brain differences because of
that so which which which is is that the
brain difference is causing the sexual
orientation or the behavior you know
homosexual behavior causing the changes
in brain structure that's unclear here
yeah I've actually heard that the brain
of someone who's addicted of pornography
is changed that could be a so anything
you do to yourself an expose yourself to
a can can't change your brain hmm all
right so the next one here is the
genetic hypothesis the big question
there is is there a gay gene hmm so this
has been big in science as well there's
two ways we kind of get it get at
genetics here one is to actually look
and go sequence genes and figure out I
can look at genes between you know fit
you know family or gay people and not
gay people and see if there's a
correlation between this gene and your
behavior the other way here is twin
studies these are interesting because
you can look at identical twins versus
fraternal twins versus you know just
brothers that aren't twins and you can
get a look at you know if if if one twin
is a particular way and the other twin
is that the same way you're saying well
it might be genetics right if it's you
know if it's you know one twin or the
other twin you know are the same but the
four ternal twins are the same - you
might have said well their genes are
different so maybe there's more
environment than it is genes right do
you so in in twins do you see a common
if one twin is gay the other twin well
that's that's where we will go here so I
think we're to start with it now let's
start with the genes here and we'll get
to they were called concordance studies
which are actually some of the most
informative but is there a gay gene so
this is a big question this is the
biggest one probably the most studies
this is a gene on the X chromosome this
is actually how we map a cromoz
execute 28 right so the bottom half
there that chromosome is the Q side of
the chromosome and we sort of mark you
know number bands and we get so execute
20s right at the end of the X chromosome
and what was interesting is that this
person found was his name hammer I
believe 1991 yeah MC Hammer cool but
yeah you would expect just by chance
that two brothers are gonna share a gene
about 50% of the time okay right but
they were finding a sadistic significant
so with this particular gene at 64
percent of gay brothers had the gene as
opposed to ones that were not right hmm
so what does that say and it that's kind
of complicated to interpret right
because right you would expect if you
got most people think if its genetic
it's like written in stone that's the
way you're gonna be mm-hmm and so it's
like this switch right you're expecting
a switch and what are you kind of
expecting is a hundred percent of the
time if you have this gene you're gonna
be good right if you don't have it you
know no no yeah but here it's like well
just a slight majority what does that
say well it says maybe that genes this
gene has some role in it yeah but it's
not a hundred percent it's like it could
make you a little bit more susceptible
to so probably you're inside if you're
talking yeah right if you're talking to
epidemiological terms it's increasing
your likelihood yes I can't say we
talked about that we talked about you
know diseases right we're going to live
a healthy lifestyle and I eat more fiber
right I don't reduce my risk of right
cancer that's not a guarantee but it's
not a guarantee all right
there's been other ones so you know this
has been looking between gay brothers
and looking at concordance between you
know these these particular genes some
of them now are just like we can
sequence a whole lot really quickly and
try and sequence the whole genome and
find pick out if I you know sequence
someone's genome and I give them a
survey like are you you know on that
scale of mostly you know I'm a
heterosexual or homosexual or somewhere
in between and they found a few right so
chromosome eight was one there's a gene
there
his chromosome 13 was long this is this
is fairly recent I forget the date on
that like you know just a few years ago
the interesting thing here one was the G
chromosome on chromosome 13 the gene
there it was seemed to be associated
with brain development which made them
harken back to that research on brain
differences maybe this is a gene that's
causing the differences in hypothalamus
that is pushing this one way or the
other
but again most of these are sort of in
this ballpark right we have a
preponderance that more people who are
gay seem to have this gene but here it's
kind of a correlation in this case right
and you know if you do statistics if you
take my statistic closer together by
correlation doesn't mean that's
causation you have to write more you
need correlation to show one causes the
other but it's not sufficient by itself
to say one is causing the other so are
all chromosomes have a P side and a Q
side yeah most yes most of them do
biology you know mind your P's and Q's
there you go I have not heard that joke
you should make one okay the other part
is twin studies and this is a question
you're asking about concordance so
what's interesting about this and
there's been there's more than this this
is just some of the studies that have
been done the earliest ones was
interesting they say it's a hundred
percent concordance if one twin is gay
the other one was always gay this was
criticized very quickly in the
literature because earlier studies tend
to recruit they only recruited from the
gay community specifically and so the
argument so you're getting a completely
biased you know by a sample and when so
later studies that were bigger so it
goes from a hundred percent and now
we're down in the twenty eighteen
percent range all right and so one of
the interesting things about twin
studies this is more recent one here is
that you can kind of do some I don't
know mathematical modeling of this and
try and come out okay what percentage of
this trait is genetic what percentage of
this trade is kind of individual
environmental differences so you know
and what percentage is you know shared
environmental differences right and this
is when they in this particular study
this is Langstrom 2010 this is what they
came up with
so genetic is
35 to 39 percent of the variance so
there's some genetic there mm-hmm kind
of this going along with some of these
other studies this XQ 20 mm-hmm you know
location on the X chromosome shared
environment was 0 interesting and then
the biggest factor was a unique
environmental hmm so what's the
difference between the shared and the
unique well so you know if I'm a twin I
respect I'm raised in the same household
I'm there's very similar so they found
that was zero that was not involved so
back from the 1950s hundred percent yeah
yeah today well yeah so an unique
environmental is like you know two
thirds oh wow I don't know how I was
I've been always you how do you how do
you interpret that right right yeah I
was gonna say right clarify because
because you know you kind of the
expectation I think a lot of people have
is like oh it's genetic that means you
know you clip the switch you're gay
that's it mm-hmm right or the other side
of that oh it's completely environmental
and it's due to your upbringing it's due
to your parenting it's due to and I was
abused as a child whatever it is okay no
dad or yeah yeah whatever it is that's
antifa there's more of a blend and yeah
this is 60/40 yes yes yeah 60/40 now
what is it what does that mean and I'm
not sure it's kind of tough to interpret
that this lead so this is again Bailey
his sexual orientation genetic this is
the big review paper that he put
together this big researcher you know
Northwestern University in Chicago yeah
so this is what he says about is a
genetic
based on the evidence from twin studies
we could we believe that we can already
provide a qualified answer to the
question is sexual orientation genetic
and the answer is boy it looks like a
really hedging answer somewhat genetic
but not mostly so I mean so that right
there is him going like I don't want to
be ousted and people slamming me but
yeah we're not finding the evidence to
say that it is yeah it's over sighs well
it's interesting though we know I showed
this to my class right oh you know and a
lot of them feel like oh that this is
science they just don't know what
they're doing and then the expectation
is that scientists just you know they
find the facts and
they're true and that kind of thing and
you know so they kind of chalk this up
to all Sciences less than what I thought
it was I can write it off mm-hmm I don't
think that's what's going on here I
think he's actually being honest with
the day that he's got data we've got
right you know we do have it the twin
studies seem to be that the you know the
studies that really say something right
then you know how do you interpret that
it's 40% genetic and 60% not genetic
yeah how do you how do you interpret
that into real life perhaps why God gave
us twins is literally for us to have a
window into you know first cases and
certainly is a digital experiment and
twins all throughout you know wait we've
got records of them way back in the
Bible no Jacob Anissa right demons and
so clearly had to be fraternal twins if
one is smooth and yeah right all right
so is it genetic well yes somewhat it
seems to be the answer yeah all right so
what about some of the other one
environment so this seems to point out
okay environment seems to play a big
role what types of environments do we
have so we can have two types of
environments that they talked about one
is the non social and was the social
right those are the two we talked about
before non-social often when you look at
the literature these are in fact factors
prior to birth that they talked about
this is like conditions in the womb okay
right so it's not necessarily genetic
although you know genes are involved in
expressing certain things or but when in
the literature when you look at a non
social environment it often means these
are conditions in the womb all right
isn't that crazy that something that
happens in the womb can dictate what
that baby's can experience their whole
entire life yeah I mean that that you
know the argument have you know it's not
a life until it comes out yeah you know
there's a lot of evidence that there's a
lot going on there although I still you
got to be very careful there yeah this
is one thing I point out to my class and
I think I think there are they're
pro-life people that sort of make this
leap but I don't think they should mmm
way back this is what 1500s I'm trying
to me now guy named David Humes this is
Scottish very you know this is before
atheists were really a thing but he was
about as close as you get a theist in
that time all right
he had this idea so at the time people
were sort of thinking that you know you
call it when he did science he did
natural theology and one of the things
people tried to do is say oh God's
creation is such in such a way I can
reason from that by itself to some moral
purpose so kind of a quick analogy I
don't know I went to a Christian college
and in the dormitory you know one of the
things that was pushed by the Dean was
like you know Eagles mate for life and
what's he trying to say by that because
the Eagles make a life that means you
should to it right that that's what they
were trying to do in essence I think
they have more sophisticated reasoning
but Hume pointed out that's not very
good reason what he said was that when
you go along this is the way nature is
it's this way it's this way this way and
all of a sudden you switch and say this
is therefore this is the way things
ought to be and he said there's no
logical connection communities in a lot
right because penguins will mate with
that one penguin and then the next year
it's off yeah well I mean a lot of it a
lot of birds we know that it used to
thought mates for life they pair for
life but that female sneaks out and
interesting there's a term in the
literature it's called extra pair
copulation Oh interesting
so yeah they didn't make it a rule they
basically did you know they did the
whole maury povich thing on the
offspring in the nest and found out hey
he is not the father but yeah so I mean
you know anyway you can't so yeah
basically his point is just because I
know the way things are doesn't mean
they you know way things should be and
what that translates into most
scientists think about science is that
science is about what is right so if a
developmental biologist is saying
talking about human life in during
development they're not attaching any
moral significance to that you know
saying that's outside of the bounds of
science hmm it's just biologically you
know living you know things are
happening in their chemical reactions
are happening and it's alive and it's
also human and I think it's a step too
far
for people to take that and say oh that
means we need to so that that idea that
that means something in a moral
ethical way doesn't come from science
it's coming from somewhere else hmm
certainly as Christians you would say
that's coming from let's say Scripture
right but I think we need to be very
careful when you talk about that then
we're not making science you know make
value judgments or give moral you know
so yeah that's how I feel about it too
because I think science you can yeah
this says what is I need my Bible to say
how things ought to be and how I should
bring my good point right good point all
right so okay so let's look at some non
social environment this is an
interesting effect not all of the papers
I know about actually support this but
there's been several studies that seem
to show this something called the Big
Brother effect hmm and what that means
in some papers is that if you're a
person the greater number of older
brothers you have the greater your
chances of being gay so if you've got
ten brothers your toes yeah well it's
not quite that so you're kind of
increasing your raise by 33% or so this
is what this is what it looks like in
terms of numbers right so if you have no
older brothers and maybe 2% they're
being gay and it goes up maybe a four
older brothers maybe it's up to 6% so
it's not huge yeah yeah but it isn't
affect it has been measured more than
once maybe it's because they pick on
them that's what I was thinking we had a
guest on this show who was a homosexual
champion and you're growing up and he
was the youngest the littlest the runt
always picked on that's never seemed
like he measured up even okay so he
always got along better with his aunts
and being lived in a household of girls
- yeah yeah like I was just all girls
there was no their own ain't brothers
were there no I think there were any
brothers all because and all his cousins
as well yeah all those cousins girls
certainly environmental but then also he
had father issues that played into that
actually in the literature where this
fits in you know as they call it non
social environment because the idea here
is that one theory is that maybe if a
woman carries a male child there might
be certain male characteristics that
maybe something about her immune system
is picking up on
hmm so if you have a second male child
then maybe some of those you know immune
system might cross the placenta and
attack male centers within the fetus hmm
and so the more are older brothers you
have and the more male children that
women carry is the greater that
probability of that happening no I don't
know much specific evidence that
supports that but it would help explain
this effect so that's why they're
calling it non so yeah that's why it's
confused to do with right your your
social interaction with my brother's
rights from the womb yeah so but then
again the other thing about this is that
you know we're only talking you know you
know you're only christening around 6%
and what-what-what's pointed out is this
effect by itself cannot explain the
majority of homosexuals that exists in
the United States or other places mm-hmm
so while it's interesting is the hard
facts
yeah these you can't apply that in the
same way well it's just it's just not
sufficient in terms of numbers to
explain the 4% of the population right
that is you know identifies as you know
homosexual right all right social
environment here several that have been
looked at here and there is some
interesting data here a1 recruitment
seduction this you know is interesting
it was it was a video I was kind of from
like the 1960s I think it's just black
and white and it was basically a video
like all right young boys be careful of
over-friendly
male adults because they will try and
seduce you type of thing is there data
there well maybe we do have one study
here boys who had aged discrepant which
means i they're young somebody's old you
know age discrepant early sexual
experience especially with men we're up
to seven times more likely to identify
some sexual bisexual as adults so even
if there's no biology like none of those
statistical switches or anything in
their background if something happens
somebody touched them they're more
likely that's well now for males as
éclairs less clear in females what's
going on here the data isn't quite as
clear but here we got to be careful how
we interpret this
all right as before so the other example
was we have brain studies right and the
brain stay so we have a slight
difference in the brain between you know
homosexual men and heterosexual men you
know that's more similar to heterosexual
women and the hypothalamus that kind of
you know it's kind of right the sin of
your brain near the bottom and if you go
right between your eyes straight back
how about halfway that's about where it
is all right you know that could be
interpreted two ways right you can
either say oh this is a change early in
development sort of causes you know
same-sex attractions or it's maybe the
same-sex behavior changes the brain
right so you can do it either way right
here you actually have another
explanation that people will point out
and that is remember way back at the
very beginning we found that correlation
that children who most people who were
you identified as homosexual of 80 80 85
% also had some sort of you know
childhood gender nonconformity type
stuff going on when they were young hmm
right and so people say well this might
be because they they're different from
birth and that either might attract or
you know they can be identified kind of
early on so if there's some guy who's
like oh yeah you're young and I can see
oh yeah you're also gonna end up this
way so it might be the being early on
you know you might be born that way
essentially
and then you have characteristics that
lead you to be more likely to have kind
of early encounter yeah so am I so
instead of the this early sexual
experience causing right it's that
you're actually different from you know
a young age and that's picked up on so
you're just more likely to have these
experiences hmm right
that's kind of the same thing here abuse
is similar
all right so not heterosexual adults of
both sexes are much more likely than
heterosexual adults to have experience
child sexual abuse now again it could be
the abuse causes right but again it
could be that you know if I have a child
you know non
you know gender nonconforming child that
might invite abuse so again we're sort
of ambiguous fear and what's the best
way to interpret that mm-hmm
but yeah it seems a role I mean women
you know five point three times greater
odds of or men 12 12 points 13 times
greater odds the other one parent-child
relationships this was an interesting
study here this is a huge study we've
got 12 million people kind of registry
is Danish people in this case it's not
exactly how I like being gay
specifically but it was gay marriage so
it's legal in that particular place and
so what is gay marriage associated with
well it's older mothers divorced parents
absent fathers being the youngest child
and I think some of the stories that
I've heard from people talk these come
into play in their own think oh the
person you were just talking about some
of these are coming into play right yeah
so there seems to be something
potentially there although I think you
might criticize this we're not actually
measuring whether or not their
homosexual that's whether or not they
got gay married which might be slightly
different but so you got to be careful
with the interpretation all right
parents sexual orientation this is one
sorry I think the worry especially some
christians is if you're raised in a home
or your parent is gay are you more
likely to be gay this the there's one
study that may say something like this
although it's been pointed out it has
some problems but here this is yeah
compared with children and still intact
biological families children with
homosexual experienced mothers so a gay
mother had higher rates of first one
there non-heterosexual orientation and
then a bunch of other stuff unemployment
welfare assistance having experienced
coercive sex I have you been raped right
depression you know drug use etc this
would be a complicated study because if
you have almost sexual couple raising a
child and they don't turn out gay you'll
say see it was genetic he wasn't gay
well yeah they do turn out gay you see
it was genetic father was gay so yeah
well that's why you got to be careful
when you do understand the statistics
when you do statistics you're trying to
look at stuff on average and
get away from cherry picking right would
you intend to do I like this data point
because the confirms that I already
believe as opposed to trying to get at
what's going on in general with all the
data all right now with with men yeah
homosexual so if you have a gay father
you deal still have some of the other
stuff welfare assistance stuff like that
but they didn't find more likely to be
gay the problem with the study was they
these findings make be confounded by
divorce which means that a lot of these
like welfare assistance especially with
women you know let's say I'm in a
relationship I have a kid I decide I'm
gay is that in the relationship right so
now that the mother potentially she has
custody of the kids
and she's just lost a big source of
income and now she you know so women and
sometimes women who are divorced they
struggle because they know I have to
pick you know looking after the kids
plus try and hold down a job and that
leaves them into welfare assistance and
depression and drug use accessories etc
so the study wasn't very clear but it
does maybe there's a hint of indication
maybe mm-hmm
but yeah here's basically the collusion
through all that we've gone through all
of them now mm-hmm
this is what Bailey and his paper a big
giant review paper said no causal theory
of sexual orientation has yet gained
widespread support Wow so what's the
take-home here I don't know what do you
guys hear yeah we don't know we don't
know yeah you can't put your finger on
it and say 100% it's the biology we're
born this way right which is what
popular media I mean really this kind of
a conversation probably there's very few
of young kids that are exposed to this
kind of data this kind of information
there's kind of a class yeah and I'll
guarantee you they are exposed way more
to that I'm born this way Lady gaga
scientific perspective yeah I mean well
so that's the thing I mean trying to
read scientific literature it's not
something that right really easy to do
there's a lot of understanding those in
there I mean I've been fortunate to have
the education to really get into it but
try and write you know there's a lot of
stuff that goes on in science that
doesn't trickle down into
popular culture that really should write
write it which is why we wanted to do a
show like this it's really to kind of
lay down like hey look we did a couple
shows we showed listen this is what the
populace is pushing as normal they're
making TV shows about it right I mean
they're just putting this out there as
as you know this is this is this is the
way that it is but when you look at the
scientific data and you kind of try to
put your finger on both of those that
really say in quite different things and
even the take home that I appreciate
from this conversation as well is not to
make a generalized statement even on the
Christian side yes and and to just
basically say you know oh well you know
it's all choice and it's all family
environment and everything right because
there is actually some scientific basis
for listen some people are struggling
with this thing yes they really have a
lot of pre factors that fit into that
yeah so yeah and that's actually one
thing I mean Bailey here in his paper is
big review paper here he does kind of
want to make the case so there's a part
of his paper that really cuz this is the
best case for you actually being born
that way mhm and let's just kind of show
you what that is for a moment it comes
with these two things that he's really
pointing out one is this gender
nonconformity early right so you can
pick up these kids very early and you
really can't call a gender
non-conforming child gay or straight you
don't have you know you does until
puberty you start having sexual
attraction to all and so because he says
you can identify it here you can dent
off' i it as an adult that that's strong
evidence to him anyway that maybe they
are some sense in some way whether it's
genetic environmental whatever it is
they might be born that way the other
part was they're very interesting he he
picks up on is this this is an
interesting
he follows so kind of the 1960s up
through seventies even in maybe your
late you know 90's doctor is kind of
dealt with certain malformations you
know these are these are congenital
defects you're born with
the idea at the time was what's good in
psychology I think was blank slate
theory the idea that everything about
you know how you internalize your
sexuality is all culture this was the
academic view for a very long time
hmm it's not anymore but at the time it
was and so the idea was that IQ could if
somebody has just really messed up
genitals especially males right so
females if they have messed up generals
is easy to easier to make a vagina of
and a penis surgically right so what
what what hey what this guy does these
follows them so cloaca exstrophy is a
you know statistical general defect
which kind of messes up your lower
abdomen and can mess up your genitals if
you're a guy and so the idea was all
right we know you're a male let's say
we've done the we do we know your
chromosomes right but you know it's just
a lot easier to make a vagina than a
penis surgically so we're just gonna
give you a vagina however you raised a
girl and you'll be fine you'll be a girl
all right and so this guy followed them
there's a few here this one I'm scared
of these surgical accident I know this
is the circumcision gone wrong but it's
like so again we've messed up your
genital surgically now I'll just give
you a vagina I call you a girl oh hi all
right would be the wars yeah so this is
what they do so what have we got here
one two three four five six seven cases
right where this followed and he said
all right we are going to all right
you're just a girl Laura's your girl if
you look at there at the very end all of
them tend to be most all of all but one
are identifying as male when they grow
up Wow
and all of them even though there's
sexual parts even though they were
surgically made female and probably
given hormones probably in the whole
thing which that's a very interesting
study based on that whole transgender
because I mean we pored over stuff for
the transgender topic yeah I watched a
ton of regrets videos I mean it was just
people that literally were just crying
out to the cameras going I wish I would
have never done this I mean this is just
well that's a whole other discussion
yeah this did not solve what was going
on
who we really are has a lot to do with
those chromosomes and if you're male it
just it also might depend on how things
develop did I get hormones at the right
time you know all kinds of stuff might
go into this but this is his point
really it's like even though I
surgically change these people it did
not change their sexual orientation on
the vast majority and so based on those
two things is gonna argue all right we
don't know what's going on here but you
could argue though the best evidence is
yeah for most gay people and I'm not
sure he makes any blanket I mean it
could be different people have different
reasons I don't know but you know that
there is a case to be made that yeah
you're born that way so let's get back
to here you know I I often think when
when we when you phrase it this way
probably phrased it in a probably
incorrect you know the the crux of the
argument often in popular culture is
born this way right but is it really
threatening to a biblical worldview if
they really are born that way
no so the interesting thing that if you
look at the theology there that I was
gonna pondering there it was you know
I'm beautiful in my way cause God makes
no mistakes I'm on the right track baby
I was born this way is that proper a
Christian theology right there no well I
think we're all born sinners and you
know there might be some data to say you
might turn out more to have more of an
addictive personality with but the thing
is is we're drawn to sin whether it be
drugs or homosexual lifestyle or
anything and and and that's where my
understanding of it is in the topic of
addiction yeah you know if your parents
were alcoholics you were conceived in
alcoholism you're gonna come out more
prone to alcoholism okay so yes
technically you are born that way but
it's not something that like God doesn't
make a mistake yeah it's almost like
it's kind of trying to interesting to
try it because it's the argument almost
seems to be that God made you perfect
just the way you are so stay there yeah
so you're fine just where you are
and I'm not sure yeah I don't think
that's biblical I mean the version of
Born This Way from the Bible is you know
this is Psalm 51 this is like this is an
awesome song by the way he was the one
where you know date Nathan the Prophet
confronts David because he you know
killed a man to take his wife as his
David and Bathsheba so this is him
repenting from men's in hmm so you know
it's like you know wash me and all that
kind of stuff you know great song but
this is this is one of the verses I
verse 5 surely I was sinful at birth
send for from the time my mother
conceived me hmm and so this is kind of
the biblical version of born that way
mm-hmm and that would say you know and
one sense God doesn't make mistakes but
there's another sense in scripture that
that the care is all the way through the
theme from the beginning to end way back
in Genesis it's humans have screwed up
mm-hmm and there is you know the fallout
from that means that we have a
propensity to sin hmm
sometime you know have maybe I guess
it's temptations right we might have
powerful biologically-based temptations
all right that in some cases you know we
have a very very hard time and nobody
actually succeeds in resisting all of
them right you know we this might get
you in trouble ok so I'm gonna throw it
out here anyway yeah what if you're a
parent and you notice that your child
has a propensity or you think I think
leaning more towards homosexuality you
know what what how do you grapple with
that oh boy I think that's out of my pay
grade I mean do you guys want to take a
stab at that ha ha I think I do if I
would want to go to find a psychologist
somewhere I did try and address that
question I'm not sure what I would do
myself
it sounds like based on some of the data
how you raise that child is gonna have a
there's some weight and how they're
going to turn out at least
environmentally I'm the nature of nature
and nurture but yeah I don't know my
point I was gonna make was based on the
verse that he just shared you know it
seems like born this way is a
is a logical fallacy for continuation
you know if I am born that way therefore
I do not need to change if you go at the
the psalm 51 you know I'm born a sinner
if I'm born with propensity toward
alcoholism does that then mean I should
stay in alcoholic the rest of my life
because I was born that way to me it
seems inconsistent with the Bible that
whatever way were born we should only
stay that way and never change and true
in David's case oh I was conceived in
sin I'm a sinner I killed this guy I
stole his wife so I might as well he's
going Yeah right he's room he's real
Amenti that i think that's the part of
what with the what the lyrics I'm Lady
Gaga so I'm sort of stuck out of it like
if that's the case that God makes no
mistakes you're perfect you're born that
way that sucks out the entire core of
Christianity exactly because it's the
core of it is repentance right coming to
Christ recognizing your sin you're a
sinful human being and coming to Christ
and it sucks that comes Jesus would not
need to come if there was no change yeah
you just be perfect I just take away a
cross or there would be no waiting
what's the point
yeah well there'd be no yeah this
doesn't even come yeah cuz we're all
perfectly anywhere so your worldview
would dictate how you would navigate the
issue because you have a child that
looks like they're gonna be homosexual
we're taught Oh embrace that tell him
it's okay and to keep doing it if it was
my kid seems to like the beer I let him
try here's another one buddy or an
alcoholic like your old dad you know
yeah that happens in that so the Bible
says were to raise up a child the way
that they should you got you know yeah
just yeah I think the caveat on that is
that there are no guarantees there are
no guarantees and yeah yeah so I think
it was interesting I heard it was
commentary on like the book of Proverbs
right so that's where that comes from
and the and I tend to agree them what
they were saying was that those things
that are said there's no proverbs are
just sort of wise sayings in general
rules of thumb they're not necessarily
prom
hmm right so there's no guarantee that
if I do everything right with my child
that they're going or not I'm just
coming but maybe on average we hope that
they will I guess yeah on the other hand
the other thing though is I think you
know the thing would be very very
careful of is doing the wrong thing
because you know there I've in the name
of oh my you know okay cuz you know I
think that gender and certainly gender
roles and all that stuff has changed
hugely over mm-hm
you know it's between biblical times and
now between because the nuclear family
really didn't exist in biblical times it
was you know this big extended family
right and so you know to you know you're
blamed with a doll not a truck smack the
kid that's probably he can do more harm
than good doing that so I'm not see
that's why I'm very late you know that's
why I guess I'm conflicted about what
what do you do about that I don't know
it's a difficult and sensitive subject
and you know when you get to that place
which there are many families I know
that are dealing with this and for
circumstantial whether it be social
environment or even biology you know of
the child growing up with with something
leaning to that I mean I've talked with
parents before and it's just just rips
at them so I mean I think first and
foremost you would really spend some
serious time prayer you know God what
how do I deal with this you know how
should I treat this because you know
it's a difficult subject and until you
go through that I'm sure personally
right to know how you're gonna cross
that bridge you know yeah actually I was
gonna you know bring up this Dexter this
is Paul in Romans 7 and he's talking
about the struggle he has right and it
seems like there's this deep I give me
he might call it the flesh it's deep
visceral part of him that he just says
they can't control right he says you
know for I do not do the good I want to
do right what the evil I do not want to
do this I keep on doing now if I do what
I do not want to do it is no longer I
who do it but sin living in me if it
does it always like this is this a
powerful maybe temptations I have that I
can
and overcome right and of course he goes
on to say right what wretched man I am
who will rescue me from this body that
is subject to death and thanks be to God
who delivers me through Jesus Christ our
Lord that shows our absolute need for a
savior and every day we we were just
messed up yeah so I mean being born that
way sort of fits into here but that
doesn't mean born that way doesn't
necessarily justify anything that you do
stay that way yeah that's kind of it
that's kind of the thing that I see a
puppy collection born this way stay that
way right as opposed to yeah so the
other part to bring out here is just the
idea of temptation there's a separation
between temptation and inaction right so
this is this is Christ here right where
we have a high priest this is in Hebrews
referring to Christ it was unable to who
is yeah who is able to empathize with
our weaknesses but we have one who has
been tempted in every way as we are just
as we are and yet he did not sin so the
temptation isn't the problem I think
this is this is a thing that I think we
forget when we talk about any sexual
issue right oftentimes and I think of
this you know this is a parable as often
brought up this is the woman caught in
adultery hmm right so these are you know
religious leaders Pharisees they're
trying to trap Jesus they apparently
entrap this woman right and drag her to
the feet of Jesus and say what she
wanted to do Moses has stoner do this so
they are the accusers she has done wrong
she knows she's done wrong they're the
accusers and you know what does Jesus do
in this situation is he one of the
accusers I mean no he's not he starts
writing in the dirt and certainly
doesn't actually say in the passage what
he's writing right but you know one good
interpretation is actually writing out
the sins of the people who brought her
right drop their stuff right as they
drop their and like part of the Mosaic
law was yeah you had to be sin or not
have any other sin to the one that cast
her sin
so if he's writing in the ground and
he's giving them a ritual oh yeah what
all you guys are doing let's see that's
the thing that I think we've often
Christians have often been they haven't
been Christ in this situation I think
oftentimes Christians have been those
accusers I want to uphold this
skander I would have be the moralizing
right that we talked about at the very
beginning hmm and we got to think very
hard and carefully about how we go about
approaching this issue because we often
come off as I'm holier than that hmm and
what Jesus is doing with those people
saying wait a minute you know where
Halle GU and this woman are actually in
the same boat you just don't recognize
and writing out there soon and I think
that's what we've got to remember is
that we're all well I and and and I
think that goes the other the other
thing that I see is that sometimes
church is not a safe place to be a
repentant sinner hmm and so AFI and I've
seen this in a few places one I had a
student one time come to me and he was
you know it's kind of part of the class
that I teach and he was struggling with
like bisexual issues and he's like I
mean what I took from him was that yeah
I understand that you know this is a
temptation whatever and may you know I
agree with the idea that you know what's
the Christian social sexual ethics you
know in this in this situation but he's
studying to be a pastor hmm who does he
tell who does he get help from right is
that the minute the congregation finds
out he's gone oh yeah for sure right so
and that I think that that happened I
think that's that's that's kind of the
the judgmental culture that's been
imbibed by a lot of these you know LGBT
LGBT groups is and that's why they feel
the church is very judgmental and
whatever because they see us as the role
of the accusers of this woman instead of
a redeem somebody who gives them hope
and so yeah I think that's that's the
call to Christians to try and you know
walk that road recognize that you know
you and whatever person whatever sexual
issue is going on
you're in the same boat the only
difference is we know about that person
they don't know how like I'm doing right
so yeah I think this example that you
brought up here is a perfect example
even dealing with homosexuality because
whereas Jesus was not condemning so to
say you know like even when she says
where are your accusers you know they're
not here
he didn't just stop this point right
here he literally turned to her and said
go and sin no more there's a moral line
here that that that that the Bible is
very clear about in the topic of
homosexuality
often what homosexuals hear is if you're
a homosexual you're not going to heaven
but they miss the rest of that verse
that says if you lie if you cheat if
you're at a I mean we are in danger of
adultery in the same way that a
homosexual isn't in danger of adultery
where I have kind of an take up an issue
with the topic is when people just say
I'm gonna take out white out and I go I
don't like this I'm gonna wipe that out
I don't like this because if you said
that in the same realm of like stealing
I'm a klepto I like to steal things in
right and you know III think it should
be okay so I'm just not gonna read the
Bible verses that talk about stealing
I'm gonna skip over that you can't do
that because then you've now shifted the
moral line to what you are interpreting
it right I think the same way with
homosexuality is it's like there is a
moral line here that the Bible is very
clear on and it's very clear on on all
those other sins that go along with it
but to single one out or to erase one is
is where we get well that reminds me was
it it's it's Romans 1 I think that's one
of those lists of you know you know as
text that talks about homosexuality but
it also talks about this vast majority
other that we are indeed yeah like
disrespectful to parents I think is one
of those right or lying or gossip I
think is there too so the balance is
upholding a moral line but at the same
time doing the other thing that Jesus
was trying to teach and that is you
still need to love your fellow man you
need to love your brother you need to
care about them you need to you know be
encouraging them you need to be praying
for them not demoralizing them because
everybody has something that they're
struggling with right that's right
and it's just that we know what some
people are struggling over other
and so it's yes we need to uphold what
the Bible tells us you know we should
strive to reach for but at the same time
don't demonize everybody else who's
having a problem because we're all
having problems right yeah I think
there's one more aspect to that that we
need to be careful of and that there's
some council that Paul gives and I'm
talking about what is done I think it's
first Corinthians I'm trying to say like
7 somewhere in there but he's basically
telling addressing sexual immorality in
the church right so it's what a man has
his father's wife as now he puts it and
he's very hard on that and saying you
know kick this person out but he at the
very end he makes this interesting he
kind of shifts right and he says okay uh
if you're in a body of believers right
and you all have this agreed-upon set of
standards right then if somebody's
flaunting them then they really don't
belong and that's why you expel the
immoral brother right but he says do not
judge people who are outside the church
mmm interesting and so cuz it is well
then you'd have to go at the world
didn't have no one to evangelize and
that's what you see with Christ here I
mean one of the things that Christ gets
accused of is hanging out with tax
collectors and sinners he's hanging out
with these people I don't think they
feel that he's judging them when he's
doing that right
certainly he's trying to win them over
and show them love and stuff like that
but he's not judging them in fact these
you know the people in this story these
are the gym people a stone this person
we've judged you you're worthy of death
Christ saves her right and so I think
one of the things we often do it we
often look out at society and say oh
you're this and you're that and you're
gonna go to hell and whatever else and
the bands that don't do that don't judge
people who are outside hmm yeah let the
Holy Ghost grab their heart and once it
you're a Christian now now let's show
you what what being a Christian is like
right so once yeah once they're here and
then they can be confronted with all
right this is what the Bible says and
what it doesn't stay and you know then
you know that's on them to come to that
and decide this is what I wanna do
I know that happened in my own life and
I was still drinking and smoking weed
and living with a woman as a Christian
and as I began to actually read the
Bible well do something about that yeah
hmm so yeah that's that's why that's
kind of gets back to you know this
moralizing let's not be judging the
world let's you know you know have have
this you know but what Peter talks about
we have a have an answer for people who
asks for the hope that you have why you
believe what you believe why you do what
you do but you don't have they're
beating them over the head with it
mm-hmm yeah and the other thing to
remember here is that this no matter
which you know if it's more liberal more
conservative academic literature all of
we're agreeing on the people who are
non-heterosexual are at some risk
they're more likely to omit suicide more
likely to be depressed more likely to
have anxiety disorders and so we're
really not a you know oftentimes I think
there are Christians you see these
people these are sexual deviants they're
evil let's shun them whenever these are
people that need help some of some of
the reason why they're likely to have
these is because of judgmental attitude
is that they run across from society
from Christians there's no hope for me
even the Christians hate me yeah right
there's no hope yeah exactly we're not
offering hope who will all right all
right so you know we got to be and that
like yeah all sexual I mean one of the
ones that I had a conversation with
somebody recently is that pedophilia now
if you find yourself so pedophilia is
interesting because not all pedophiles
are predators
so our child predators and not all child
predators or pedophiles hmm there might
be a higher risk there if you are a
pedophile that you might but there
there's different things and I think
that's the same thing as temptation
versus action right mm-hmm
but yeah if you find yourself in a
position where I mean the definition of
a pedophile is someone who's sexually
aroused by prepubescent children right
let's say you find yourself in that
position like
I recognize that for whatever reason
that child is you know I'm becoming
sexually aroused by children what do you
do you might recognize no that's wrong
I should not act on that but I'm going
to struggle with that who do what where
do I go in this society you go nowhere
right you can't reach out to anybody
well church included that normal though
I don't know I have a see that's the
issue we talk about life you technique
comparing and contrasting with say
pedophilia with homosexuality pedophilia
has a clear victim mm-hmm right and we
know that if you sexually abused a child
that's messes them up for a long time to
come
so there's a clear victim there and I
don't really see society normalizing
that because of the child is a victim
homosexuality is different because
societally there is no clear downside
there is no clear people getting messed
up if two consenting adults doing what
they do right who cares
and so that's I think that's you know I
think it's it's as much like it's much
easy to see the downside and for even
secularly people to recognize why
pedophilia it's you know let's it not
pedophilia shouldn't say preying on
children knowing is we got to make that
distinction between pedophile and child
molester because they're they're not the
same thing so yeah so that I think that
that distinction we can think about and
that's why it's harder to make a case to
a secular audience that homosexuality is
wrong because they're looking what they
think is wrong needs to have some
societal harm that's big and obvious for
them to recognize that this is probably
not something good and it's it's harder
to make that case with homosexuality
which is why I think it's you know
that's part of the reason why it's
coming to the floor or why you know gay
marriage is legalized why it's being
more accepted even among Christians in
the u.s. so that's yeah I think there's
a distinction there with homosexual
groups
well did it probably from probes
promising yeah I think that's the thing
so there are Christian groups that will
will say that homosexuality is okay and
the strongest case they really have for
that is that the forms of homosexuality
that existed in biblical times are
different than they are today and so the
argument would be it's not the
homosexuality percent
it's you know if you're gonna be a
homosexual you need to be monogamous be
faithful all those things that go with
regular marriage right
so those churches would say well you
know the AIDS epidemic and how that got
started it was somewhat I don't know it
was it was associated with certain very
promiscuous gay lifestyles you know in
San Francisco and other places that made
a sweep across that you has and so they
would say no they push you there is the
promiscuity not the homosexuality mmm so
really where we where we are then is you
know it's how you interpret Scripture in
this case you know and I think you know
at least for me the best interpretation
is yeah this behavior is not okay but
that's something I think somebody who is
in that position needs to come you know
be shown love and then come in and then
recognizes your story right we're all
right I'm convicted not by somebody
beating me for the head but by my
encounter with Jesus through Scripture I
had one more text here okay let's do it
all right this is this is this is right
after Jesus was just called Levi Matthew
all right so Levi Matthew is a test
collector and this is where I use a
little major place where useless accused
of hanging out with tax collectors and
sinners because Levi Matthew throws this
great banquet for Jesus with all his
friends and then the you know the powers
that be that come em to ya why are do
you eat and drink with tax collectors
and sinners so Jesus right there with
them and really I mean in that culture
the Jewish people at that time they're
under Roman rule right and they don't
want to be under Roman rule there's
Messiah to come to kick out the romans
and set up this great kingdom and so if
you're a tax collector what are you
you're a Jew you're collaborating with
Romans you are a traitor you're about
the lowest of the low you even below
sinners in this case I think if you're a
tax collector right and those are the
people Jesus is hanging out with right
and so those are the people who's
bringing hope and then you know jesus
answered them it is not the healthy you
need a doctor but the sick i have not
come to call the righteous
but sinners to repentance and to try and
unpack that right what does he what does
he mean by that
you know not come to call the righteous
and in this case he's talking to these
Pharisees right and what he's really
saying is you think you're righteous
I'm not time to tell people who like you
know mmm who think they're righteous who
think they're high and mighty you think
they're on a different moral plane than
everybody else I've come to meet sinners
and so I absolutely all need to
recognize that need we're all in the
same boat doesn't matter Julia hmm so so
basically take home is is really you
know we need to come at this topic
especially with outside of the church
with a lot of compassion with a lot of
understanding you know that all of these
different variables have gotten these
people at this place right and you know
win them over with the love like Christ
has won them over
so that's that's that's a that's a good
takeaway and I appreciate the science
and the research that's you know really
trying to explain a lot of these these
these very difficult topics for us to
understand so it's awesome there will be
some comments on this one for sure well
we want to thank you guys for checking
this out don't forget Dr Corbett here is
has got a channel remind us of the
nature and revelation nature and
revelations there's a podcast where can
we find the podcast nature and
revelation o RG okay matron and and
revelation orgy check it out you know
hopefully we can have you back on the
show we'll do some more because I think
the scientific perspective is really
very interesting to me as we kind of I
think it's a big I mean it's a you know
it is it is the I mean I was I was I was
looking at was it was a book on
scientific velocity I look through and
what it pointed out is in the modern age
like if you were 100 years ago and you
want anyone to pull in an expert you'd
pull in Claridge it you'd pull in a
pastor right nowadays who do you pull in
right the scientist a scientist so
modern culture listens to scientist
often more than they listen to yeah
that's right
so you know in this particular topic
especially you know in dealing with the
topic are we born this
I mean there was some very interesting
stuff that came out of some of this
research and that really kind of showed
us you know hey there are some evidences
on on the biological side that we do
have some some propensity that might
push someone towards that but really a
large portion of it is not as well so we
hope you found this beneficial to us
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button hit that notification bell so you
can get to all the newest latest and
greatest videos that we've done and
thank you for watching our videos we got
lots of there on these types of subjects
and if you got any comments that you
want to talk about this or anything you
want us to cover in the future put it in
the description or the the comment
section below and we will try to cover
it for you guys thanks for watching
[Music]